the leader
at that time came to america for help
they turned him down
to bring westernized philosophy back to
his country then russia said yes then he
brought communism down to
vietnam and everything can you mind
sharing that story yeah so you know the
french are trying to call on the
indo-china award what people don't
understand is they think the vietnam war
is only the american involvement
my mother was born in war yeah that was
france's mess right the indo-china war
like by the time the vietnam war ended
for my parents they've been at war for
close to 20 years
right and that's what people understand
so what patrick was saying is ho chi
minh came in and they were trying to
colonize he you know he started seeing
the divide between
his country right vietnam so you had the
south vietnam you had the north it's
clearly a divide in ideology right so uh
he first he came to uh the americans he
asked for help but we didn't want any
vomit there
because we didn't want to go against our
french allies and they did have a point
the friend the the french were were
being brutal with their plantations
the french were
they they were colonizing america like
they were colonizing uh you know vietnam
like they it was still africa and
america centuries before it was
imperialism from the 1800s still going
on annual imperialism yeah it was
plantations there was slavery
yes but what what they what they didn't
understand was the the vietnamese people
they're trained
with the
warfare of sanju
right that means unconventional work as
a green beret i'm telling you i'm a
master on conventional warfare we found
our independence as americans in the
revolutionary war under unconventional
warfare so when the french try to
colonize they're facing an
unconventional warfare
type of army sanju type of tactics so
they're having a hard time and
ho chi minh went to americans and asked
for help we didn't have any interest
there he went to the russians obviously
that that communist ideology was uh
embedded into ho chi minh he only cared
about uniting his country under one
country again
right so communism came uh the the
russians started supporting the the
communist ideology the north vietnamese
grew the armies and they raised
unconventional warfare against a
conventional force of americans so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]